now texas officials say at least 50
migrants are dead after being trapped in
a truck that had no working air
conditioning or water it was discovered
near san antonio where temperatures have
been over a hundred degrees
sixteen survivors including four
children were rushed to nearby hospitals
for heat stroke and exhaustion police
detained three people in connection with
the incident but texas governor greg
abbott is pointing the finger at the
president's border policies tweeting
these deaths are on biden
meanwhile we are also learning that the
administration has quietly signed a
five-year lease on an abandoned school
to house thousands of unaccompanied
migrant children in north carolina sean
i come to you first on this that the
state's eight republican house lawmakers
have written a letter to the president
saying this contradicts what you said
previously about these minors this comes
as a complete surprise to us and our
constituencies and they point out that
in addition to the lack of transparency
by this administration they say due to
your failures to secure the southern
border every state including
north carolina is now suffering from the
impacts of this border crisis especially
those children well of course you don't
have just a legal migrant in in texas
arizona and california they're being
shipped throughout the country but this
i mean this this story of 48 migrants
dying in a trailer is horrific the
inhumanity of an open border so it's not
just the death and trailers
it's the the drugs that come across our
border you know young americans die you
have the sex trafficking
um that happens and i think the
democrats do this i'm trying to wrap my
head around and maybe jessica will speak
to this but is this about politics are
they trying to win votes with open
borders because if you look at the
hispanic vote that has a 24 approval
rating for joe biden you would say
listen this is not what hispanics care
about they actually want jobs they want
lower gas prices they want prices to go
down in the grocery store they hate crt
they hate the transgender teaching in
schools they actually want to have
schools teach math history science and
so again i think democrats are getting
this wrong and if joe biden would just
go back to securing the border maybe
stop uh suing on remain in mexico and
actually let that trump policy stay we
might have a little more secure border
and less people flowing into the country
and less tragedy i'll let you answer
that and also folding in if i may you
know we've learned that since early 2017
one of every three people held at border
facilities border patrol facilities is a
minor right this is coming out new that
this is new data that is essentially uh
confirmed that out of almost two million
people detained more than 650 000 were
under 18. so the argument just taking
that carrying the ball a little further
is that with these compassionate
policies at the southern border they're
actually so cruel because no one is
using them more than those cartels that
are taking advantage of these migrant
children that now are being absorbed by
north carolina and throughout the
country by an administration that
refuses to admit or be transparent about
any of their decision making
i wouldn't go that far to say that
they're refusing to be transparent about
any of their decision-making and no
we're not doing it to win votes
there's a core constituency of the
democratic party
on the far left that does think that we
should have an open border and they're
very open about that that is not joe
biden's position it is not the vice
president's position on it or the bulk
of the party there are a number of
outspoken democrats mostly border
democrats who have said absolutely leave
remain in mexico in place until we have
a good plan to get us out of it and kind
of breathes a sigh of relief when a
judge said actually this has to continue
and it seems like the mexican president
wants to work with us more on that and
obviously he's incredibly upset about
this humanitarian disaster with these 48
dead so far
in that truck in terms of
unaccompanied minors coming across the
border it is a relief to hear you say
that since i always hear it's just
single men right that that's who's
coming over and they're coming to you
know destroy the country or whatever
kind of fear-mongering about it who's
saying that
that's what
non-stop footage
that i have seen coming out of
right-wing channels about this is who's
coming into your homes this is who's
coming across the border and it is
children and people are in desperate
situations and they know that children
are not going to be turned back they
also do have a right to claim asylum
here and they should go through the
system and they should be processed and
it needs to be done better i am not
an advocate for an open border system in
any way this is joe policy right i mean
joe biden is is the president of course
he's the president and when he sues on
remaining in mexico he wants to remain
in mexico i don't go away he's not doing
anything to secure the border and he
could i agree with you on the far left
constituency but joe biden has embodied
that far leftism as opposed to the
border democrats who are like listen
this is horrible policy change it joe
biden i won't i'm more in that camp that
says we need a solution to this before
you get rid of this policy but i would
add that there's a bit of strangeness
around these headlines that you see it
was even from this open borders uh just
seized you know pounds and pounds of
fentanyl is the border open then or
hundreds of thousands of migrants
detained does that make it an open
border it seems like border patrol is
doing their job and they are 1.5 million
illegal border crossings in fiscal year
2022 alone it's a record yes the border
is open and here on outnumbered we've
covered the children uh in a way that i
would argue no other network has because
there has been an expose on cbs there
was one i believe it was at nbc about
emergency intake facilities about little
boys complaining that they were getting
feathers and bloody and raw chicken in
joe biden's america in these facilities
kids on suicide watch list girls age 13
to 17 urinating in bags where's msnbc i
thought you guys were great
humanitarians where's cnn where's joe
biden why isn't the media allowed we
cover here on outnumbered i'm proud that
we do on our show kids crossing the
border but this is the humanitarian joe
biden america where fentanyl kills
americans
where illegal immigrants cross the
border where children languish away in
emergency intake facilities and 50
migrants die and what is the biggest
mass atrocity we've seen on our southern
border well done humanitarians good job
kamala that's right and that's why
multiple states attorneys generals in
addition to district attorneys have
raised that alarm and all of these
fronts right they've said these children
are the ones that are being absolutely
overlooked neglected sexually assaulted
with the dearth of background checks
that people need to go under and i think
there's a level of responsibility this
administration absolutely holds but
because they are being discarded the
cartels are discarding these people they
are discarding these kids so too is this
administration when 50 people die in a
tractor trailer and that's somehow
acceptable that's going to be ignored
i'm sure we will not hear one peep from
anyone in this administration and the
fact that fentanyl as we now know is the
leading unnatural cause of death for
american kids 18 and 25 let alone those
coming across the border digging i want
to play a clip for you from one of the
sheriffs down there who reacted to the
fentanyl situation we referenced it on
our tees stand by we'll watch
come monday morning i learned of this
release and i was infuriated i could not
believe that we had 150 000 fentanyl
pills one of the most dangerous
epidemics that is facing our nation
today
with people in custody that we may
potentially be able to impact the future
of this type of drug trafficking
organization and or cartels in
california in my county and we let them
go and we let them go it is tandem human
smuggling and the narcotics industry
that these cartels are engaged in and
again who is being discarded humans dead
migrants and children that are now being
absorbed by our system well children are
being poisoned to death by fentanyl
across this country and i haven't seen
anybody in the body administration go
into a funeral
can we go to a few funerals i said this
at the very beginning of the biden
administration when they started rolling
back the immigration policies biden and
company have intentionally laid the
foundation to allow human traffickers
and drug traffickers to profit and
prosper from human misery suffering and
death
and
the fact that it hasn't been reversed
the fact that the border troll patrol is
not backed up by this administration
seems to suggest that the bid
demonstration is perfectly fine with us
i talked with mark lamb who's a sheriff
of pinal county arizona and he said can
you imagine
if that 50 people were dead in a
shooting
today the outrage that you would be
hearing and how berserk people would be
on the up from the other side of the
aisle on the left and he also pointed
out he said horrible 50 people dead in
the back of this tractor trailer he said
go back and look at all the people over
the last year and a half who've been
found
who are um in the back of u-hauls who
are being suffocated to death by drug by
uh human traffickers march of this year
17 adults one unaccompanied child found
crammed in the back of an unventilated
u-haul same month
16 migrants including a child inside a
tractor-trailer in northeast el paso
last july a migrant dead after several
other migrants were found inside a
u-haul in new mexico last june 33
migrants found crammed into a u-haul in
near 100 degree heat this death these
deaths today completely avoidable if
somebody in washington in this white
house gave a flying dam and remember
this vice president campaigned in part
on overhauling the immigration system
right but what do we have now a 1.5
million person waiting list people wait
two to three to up to five years those
that came here illegally and because of
their compassionate approach remember
they called the trump administration
cruel they say romanian mexico is cruel
and yet if that were to be reversed then
the waiting list would just
exponentially increase to me the
cruelest thing is 50 migrants dead in a
tractor trailer and this administration
looking the other way
hey everyone i'm emily compagno catch me
and my co-host harris faulkner and
kaylee mcinenneny on outnumbered every
weekday at 12pm eastern or set your dvr
also don't forget to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page for daily
highlights